ادوات تثير مشاركه منتسبين للاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه في عمليات ضد جيش
الاحتلال قلقا لدى المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
على الرغم من انهم يضعونها في سياق
العملات الفرديه اخر هذه العمليات وقعت في
14 من سبتمبر الماضي عند حاجز الجلمه شرق
جنين وشرك فيها احمد عابد الذي كان يعمل
في جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه الفلسطينيه
وادت الى مقتل ضابط اسرائيلي في العاشر من
يونيو عام 2021 شارك ادهم عليوي ورفيقه
تيسير عيسى من جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه
ايضا في اشتباكات مع قوات الاحتلال في
مدينه جنين
في الحادي والثلاثين من يناير عام 2016
اقتحم امجد السكري من جهاز الشرطه
الفلسطيني حاجز بيتقيل العسكري قرب البيره
ما اسفر عن اصابه ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
في الثالث من ديسمبر عام 2015 استشهد مازن
عربيه من جهاز المخابرات العامه في عمليه
النفذها قرب حاجز حزم العسكري شمال القدس
المحتله وادت الى اصابه جنديا اسرائيليا
بجروح